the world has changed where there's now
this like robotic arm that's a general
purpose robotic arm so think of it like
an iphone right it's a piece of hardware
that you could buy that you could
program to do anything right so when
steve jobs came out with the iphone they
were like this is iphone it can access
the internet it has a gps inside and it
can make phone calls like that's what it
could do
and from there you guys figure out the
rest right like initially they didn't
have the app store but then when they
did have the app store now all of a
sudden you get the flashlight app and
then the app that turns you know it's
like a ruler uses the camera to like
measure something then you get like
strava it's like we'll use the gps to do
this thing so it's basically like a
programmable general purpose tool so
that's what's happening with these
robotic arms
[Music]
all right we're live bro what's up
listen listen to this thing i'm going to
tell you something i uh
you know had been being really healthy
this summer and didn't eat a lot of
sugar didn't have no sugar other than
like fruits and fruits and vegetables
and like just no sugar added today i
decided today was my planned cheat day
after three months of like doing this
and i ate some ice cream
um
i feel miserable yeah the cheat day is
always underwhelming it's always like
i'm looking forward to it i'm planning
for it then i start doing it i don't
even feel good while i'm eating it
well it's like it's like um
when you drink and then the next day
you're hungover you're like why did i do
that but then you immediately do it
again like a few days later i kind of
feel like that except instead of like
three days it's like it's 10 minutes so
like i eat something and 10 minutes
later i'm feeling horrible i'm like oh
[__] it there's still some left though i
should probably do it oh my god i feel
so sick you have such an extreme
personality you you always go to these
extremes um you also i feel like this is
also why people hate
uh like fit people is because they like
have these types of problems and normal
people are just like what are you
talking about uh like what is the big
deal why are you doing this to yourself
why are you waking up in the middle of
the night thinking about ice cream it's
like
the way that you know the way that some
people get annoyed about
like crossfitters and you know like
people who love to talk about
intermittent fasting i think there's
people who feel that way about us with
business and money which is just like
dude not everything's a business it's
okay and i would say that if we succeed
we we need to succeed in creating people
that are as annoying as crossfitters as
our fans i think that's my new goal yeah
you need freaks and here you've got you
you're at a huge disadvantage you know
why right it's because you are what i
like to call
emotionally
stable
you have too much emotional health uh
good emotional health in order to uh you
know be extreme like some people i'm
reading this great book about uh leaders
and how the guy the author looks at a
lot of like uh interesting leaders who
we like like so for example abe
lincoln's one of the most written about
i think the most written about american
figure ever winston churchill
a bunch of people like that and he
basically his whole theory is that
during okay times uh a mentally stable
leader is could be adequate but during
bad times mentally unstable leaders
typically are the best at leading
because they understand like the ups and
downs
they uh are kind of like crazy enough
kind of like when an entrepreneur like
invent something or start something
versus the type of person who just runs
it and runs it like even keel and
they're like well you kind of need some
extremes and extreme times and it like
analyzes history on emotionally unstable
people and looks at like oh they're
actually the best during bad times
well i think people underestimate this
because in theory
it sounds like you want somebody who is
stable
in theory you want let's say you join a
startup or a small company you want it
to be like oh how do we make decisions
you know we we talk about it as a group
we get a bunch of different perspectives
and then we sort of all chime in with
what we think and we go with you know
maybe the majority it's like a democracy
and actually that [__] doesn't work in
startups uh it is not the norm and that
would be the outlier if it was to work
the the norm is what they call the
benevolent dictator so it's basically
we agree for better for worse that
person's the ch the captain they're the
captain and we're going on their ship
and either we're going down or we're
going to the promised land and that's
how the best startups work is they pick
a captain and they just go ride or die
with that person and they say look for
better for worse we need to make
decisions fast so one person's going to
always be faster than a committee we
need to be
extremely decisive so we can't be torn
constantly by warring you know one group
wants a the other group wants b we can't
have that
three we need it to be a little bit
extreme because look we're trying to do
an extreme thing here so maybe we need a
bit of an extreme leader and so i think
in companies
you actually want a dictatorship
and people don't like that they're
uncomfortable with that because that's
not what you want in your country maybe
or that's not what you want in your you
know your local city but it is what you
want in a company and it is what you
want on any creative project it's kind
of my view you want kind of a crazy
genius who's going to be the creative
force driving the thing and everybody
else get on board or get off
and that's that's how you ran the hustle
that's how i run my companies is
definitely the way when it comes to to
creating new stuff from scratch yeah and
then it actually makes sense and let me
explain how i was and you tell me if
you're the same way but
if you look at like with the ceo it like
it doesn't really matter if there's a 30
uh not approval rating it's just like
do the numbers like does it work you
know for a publicly traded company it's
like uh it didn't matter unfortunately
or fortunately the way you look at it
doesn't matter if you're an [__] did
the numbers go up and did you achieve
what you said you're going to achieve
and so it doesn't matter if your
employees i mean it matters if it
becomes a retention problem but if it's
just if you have a 10 approval rating
but your numbers are great it's great if
you have a 10 approval rating and you're
the president of america well you're
you're jobless you know what i mean like
you're not going to win the next
election so it's just like all about
appeasing to one percent and because of
that we get used to this idea of like
democracy and like
you know i don't want to be led this is
like you know don't lead me just like
get me involved and so i remember when i
started my company i was like yeah
that's how i'm going to run it like look
it's this is like a meritocracy we are
all here working together and it is that
but it is definitely more like hey i'm
the boss i will take input in from
everyone i'm making the decision and
this is the way that we're going to go
and it's my job to make sure that you
feel inspired to be here and all this
other stuff and i remember feeling
really self-conscious about that and
then there'd be times where i wasn't the
leader like for example when i joined
hubspot or maybe when you and i work on
this podcast it's like well i'm not
exactly the boss and i actually felt a
lot of security and comfort when i said
hey who's the boss of this project and
you just say
is this person the boss great hey boss
uh
what you know make your decision please
and i felt actually good about like
being a follower and then i realized
that maybe i think my employees when i'm
the bot like you have to have a boss i
think and when you are the boss it is
kind of cool but also very stressful but
when you're not the boss it's like yeah
i'm okay taking
this role and
i recognize we need a leader just tell
me what to do
right yeah what do they call it one neck
to choke it's like there needs to be one
neck to choke when it comes to any
situation or any problem like if it's
like if i don't know who's in charge if
i don't know who's who actually makes
the call then you lose one really
powerful thing which is accountability
and uh and so i think that's that's
really important i think that uh you're
absolutely right i don't mind whether
i'm the person or i'm not the person in
charge i just like that there is a
person in charge i want a benevolent
dictatorship because that's what i've
had personally seen
work best i remember when we were when i
was at twitch and we did uh the first
executive off site so it's like i don't
know the the sort of like 15 exact
leaders in the company go to whatever
some fancy place they have a spread of
you know like whatever tea and crumpets
and even busters in daly city yeah
fridays
exactly you go to friday's during happy
hour potato skins at the nuclear
margarita yeah yeah you eat a loaded
potato and you you start to decide the
future of the company you got to feel
like your customers you know you got to
go to the applebee's you got to get the
nachos
so the the ceo and the ceo they get up
there and they say hey look we we read
the results from the last cer the last
offside we did last quarter
and it seemed like the big thing you
guys wanted was you felt like the
decision making was too top down
and you didn't have a say
and you feel it felt like your ideas
either weren't heard or you know the
groups you know
it was it was all just sort of mandated
from above and you just had to execute
you didn't feel empowered so this time
we're doing it different
and they like spent the whole day and it
was like what are your ideas children
and then everybody writes down their
ideas i'm sticking that's like awesome
let's do a color voting system everybody
vote on your top three and you're like
yeah and then you go through
know uh so you want to do a commercial
with the rolling stones sean you know
that
that that cost a million dollars but
okay we'll we'll take that into account
yeah who here who here keeps writing
billboards are back
back from where what is this idea about
right so it's like you basically and
then you go through this whole day
process where everybody's talking about
it and you could tell the extent in a
way they're interested but they're also
like biting their tongue a bit because
they're like look all right we said
we're not gonna just like
slam in with our opinion and just
overrule everything and be like guys
it's [__] obvious we're doing one two
and three what are we talking about here
and so they didn't do that they let
everybody do their things great come up
and we leave the off site
fast forward either the next quarter the
quarter after that so three or six
months later we go for the next off site
it's like oh we're in the feedback
uh we feel like we just don't know how
decisions are being made uh we kind of
wish that the leadership would just step
in and give us clear direction on what
we're gonna do like hey we're ready we
just need some clarity from you guys
it's called the long con man this is the
long con
and so they basically were like here
we'll let you you know try this and i
was just like am i the only one in the
room that just remembers what the last
feedback was which is the exact opposite
which is like it's too top down and now
it's like are the leaders gonna be
leaders or not like we need clarity your
job is to give us these decisions like
uh we feel like you're just sitting back
and then now it's mayhem and it's like
and so that was like the affirmation of
something i always believed the second
part there's this uh there's a skit from
the chappelle show where he wants to get
oprah pregnant so he uh you know he
wants to have oprah's baby and he gets
her pregnant and goes gotcha
and uh like that's that's how i feel
emmett is just like saying to himself
after like three months so he's like
gotcha you guys said what dave chappelle
gotcha
i'm pregnant are you sure it's man
it's yours
that's your [__] what
a little [__]
[Laughter]
the the second thing is war time and
peace time i think this also matters a
lot so you want this sort of like
dictatorship when it is wartime and for
for startup therefore company there's
usually two wartimes
there's the beginning when you're nobody
you have no customers no product no
direction you have no market share no
nothing
and then
if you start to succeed you will
hopefully enter some version of peace
time where it's like the thing is
working
we don't need to everyday wake up and
worry about dying or killing our
competitors or like all the stuff like
maybe you're working on
you know maintenance fixing bugs maybe
you're working on
um talking to customers and making sure
your support you know things that you
kind of push by the wayside now there's
more time to go do those things properly
you work on security we work on
server robustness whatever it is the
same thing but more and better a little
bit every time yeah you don't need to go
and conquer new lands you're basically
taking your existing land and saying oh
you know we need to fix up some things
around here that we ignored during the
wartime rush
but then you enter wartime again
inevitably and that's when you know the
competitive landscape changes you know a
new platform gets released competitors
emerge
um whatever
and the economy changes and being able
to shift between those two gears is
pretty tough i think very few
leaders can
be the best wartime ceo and the best
peacetime ceo usually you're one or the
other you're an amazing peacetime or
amazing wartime and then you sort of
stay too long dur when the when the when
the season shifts it's i think that's
the other thing to recognize because
people will always say oh this person's
good or bad and it's like well actually
maybe they're just amazing at one season
and the season has changed and now a
different type of person would actually
be best for what's going on now and so
uh that's the other thing about like you
know this dictatorship stuff that you
got to know is like what season are we
in if we're in wartime i want a wartime
ceo if we're in peacetime i need a
peacetime ceo and i need to know when to
shift i always hated saying this because
there were so many people who died and
it was so bad for so many people but i
remember thinking like
dude covid was awesome like i loved
i loved being in the trenches you know
like it was actually quite exciting it's
exciting now because i know how the
story ends and things end well but at
the time i was quite scared but looking
back i was like oh i feel alive like
this is this is yeah this is what it is
and honestly i kind of hate the war
metaphor because you know
first of all there's people who are
actually in war so yeah that's true this
is a it's a borrowed it's a borrowed
term and they didn't give us permission
um the second thing is
you know
our war is fought literally at a
keyboard with
clicks firing left and right and so you
know there's a part of me that just
feels very lame so yeah i felt so alive
when i was logging into google analytics
every morning and checking out you know
what was like well
do you acknowledge that you're kind of a
soft [__] right like it's like okay
yeah as long as i acknowledge that then
it's okay to continue this yeah this
metaphor but let's acknowledge it is a
metaphor it is not like real in any any
way but i know what you mean which is
that
when these big shake-ups happen or
there's a downturn
where most people's reaction is oh [__]
i'm sure you know this is bad for me and
they just go with the sheep of like it's
bad for me versus a lot of other people
recognize hey this is happening whether
i like it or not
and given that it's happening the
questions i need to ask are what
opportunities does this open up for me
where does this where am i now going to
get strong in that i was otherwise weak
in what have i been neglecting that now
it's time to put my focus on right like
just ask yourself better questions then
you start to focus on cool i'm going to
take market share in this area i'm going
to i'm going to quickly pounce on this
thing that i've otherwise been
neglecting that now matters a lot or
hey oh now that everybody's comfortable
with remote work and stuff like what
that opens up this new opportunity for
us and just ask better questions and
you'll get better answers dude speaking
of so i've got two topics here that are
like kind of related to like mad men and
crazy people the first have you ever
heard of this guy named brad uh brett
adcock
no have you heard of this company called
veterie do you remember veterie
not really okay but no i don't i
couldn't tell you what it is so this guy
named brett adcock he i just met him
recently and he joined our community and
i've been getting to know him listen to
this guy's background so he's 36 years
old he's from central illinois and in
around 2012 2015 he started a company
called veterie and it's nothing
particularly sexy it was just basically
like a job site and it was a little bit
like hired.com and eventually hired.com
tried to bully battery hired.com was
also a similar business a job board but
like you know more in depth more
technology and they raised north of 100
million dollars fast forward five or six
years later veterie ended up buying
hired.com when hired.com went bankrupt
and so veterinary was basically a job
website to help people recruit engineers
raise 10 million eventually was acquired
for 120-ish
about 150 i think so this guy brett he's
36 now so back then when it was acquired
that was in like 2015 so he was in his
20s he made low digit tens of millions
of dollars so he didn't tell me but i
would imagine in the 20 million dollar
range but here's what he did tell me
listen to this he put 100
of his money minus a little bit of cash
that he put down for a down payment for
a house so when i say 100 he told me he
goes i didn't own any outside equities i
owned nothing i had my down payment my
house and 100 of the earnings that i
made which was low tens of the million
tens of millions put into the business
bank account and then he started a
company called archer so basically they
make like these car they some people
call them flying cars they're basically
like helicopters uh helicopters but they
kind of look like a car body and i was
like how did you learn about this and he
said i learned it all on my own i read
50 engineering books and built three
generations of electric aircraft in 2018
at the university of florida where i was
doing engineering courses as an
undergrad i had to build a lab there to
have facilities big enough in 2018 and
so
with owning zero public equities outside
of archer the archer stock
he makes zero outside investments and he
said because he needs extreme focus so
he put all this money in archer archer
eventually does a spec i believe they
did us back but they but they went
public so they sold like a billion
dollars worth of these flying vehicles
to united airlines or something like
that takes it public for three or four
billion dollars now the stock is you
know like most stocks in the in the grow
space is it doing so hot but i still
think it's a billion dollar uh company
and his net worth skyrockets to a
billion i think now it's in the 300 or
400 range and makes all this money from
archer
and now i can't talk about his new
startup but i can't soon he's told me he
took
basically 200 million dollars
and he's put all of it into
his new company
and still to this day he goes the only
stock that i own is archer
and
my house that's like the only outside
investments and then now the new
business and so i go you know is your
wife and family okay with this he goes
i've been doing i've been going all in
and been doing this for 20 years they're
used to it now by now and i said well
what do you what do you think about
people who say you know you're kind of
nuts why don't you square away a little
bit of money while you can and he goes i
don't care what people think i just want
to build the future
and this guy he's not like one of these
elon musk types where he's like hard to
talk to and you like ask him a question
he's like you know so smart that he that
he can't articulate it he's like fairly
normal i guess
normal quotation marks but he's like
easy-ish he's easy to talk to he's a
personal personable charismatic guy and
you're like oh you seem very reasonable
and then he says he does this stuff and
i'm like you are insane you're a madman
and so really interesting guy totally
under the radar from central illinois
he's only 36 years old so i got along
with him because i'm from missouri
really fascinating dude
and i'm on his twitter he's talking only
about this thing called polestar is that
his new thing or that
is a
pole star is like a subsidiary or their
partner with volvo and they make really
cool cars is that what the tweet is
about i i don't know
yeah you just talked about pole star
cars the whole time okay uh wow amazing
so uh so that's incredible the so they
basically is it the are they actually
planes are they what they call vtol like
vertical uh takeoff and landing the
second one so kind of like a
helicopter-ish it looks like a
helicopter it looks like four blades
four helicopter blades attached to like
you know a honda civic
right
and why do you need this what does this
do differently than a helicopter i have
no idea
[Laughter]
i feel like question here's sam's
question
does he ask you
it's usually name where you're from
and then instead of like you know what
do you do it's like what other equities
do you own and like how much of your
personal net worth are you reloading
into your next company wow okay let's
focus on that i don't want to know
why why you've created no idea what like
actual helicopter does that's what a
website's for i don't know to take cool
pictures i don't know what are planes
for it's just like a plane i don't know
[Music]
i mean i'm looking at the website oh
it's also just cool pictures
of the aircraft
yeah
i don't give a [__] what the widget is
it makes it's a widget it's just like
this beautiful black woman getting into
this helicopter in a dress and i'm like
what's she doing what's the purpose here
and then the next photo is she's on like
a sand dune and dubai and it's like oh
did she just fly fly to the desert
[Laughter]
actual thing but okay so hold on there's
a little question or a plot hole about
the story so
it said that he had to he he was an
undergrad in 2018 but you said he sold
his company like in 2016. so he back to
school before he was in school like he
went back to school to learn how to do
this stuff
oh my god even more incredible this guy
was interesting he became an undergrad
yes and he told me he goes he goes
whenever i do something i go all in he
goes for example i'm i i'm going all in
on my latest thing i went all in on
archer he goes when i was starting
veterinary there was a time where i took
a personal loan one month because i
didn't have any money in my personal
account and we had to pay rent and he
goes this is just what i do and so he
said he wanted to learn about electric
cars or whatever this this
cool [__] is and he went and learned
about it at university of florida
wow
uh okay that's incredible speaking of
people who go all in you know uh my
buddy fer khan and he's been on the
podcast we haven't had him on a while we
should bring him back on but basically
he was my co-founder at my last startup
before we we uh it was called bebo and
we we sold it um to twitch and then
since then he left and he was i was like
what are you gonna do well you gotta say
what he did before of that
oh before he he's got a kind of a crazy
story before that he was a co-founder of
a company called applovin that went
public and it's like i don't know uh 15
20 billion dollar mobile ad network uh
mobile gaming company
so like one of the fastest growing
companies ever
yeah just an incredible story like
they've only they only ever raised four
million dollars and they took that four
million of external capital so they took
i think four million from the founders
and four million from
uh from like strategic investors and
they turned that into basically like 20
billion of equity value which is and it
makes insane capital efficiency three
billion a year in revenue so it's like a
big business
and they like rotated they were a mobile
ad network and then they went public and
when they were going public it was like
mobile ad network their comps were not
very good because most mobile ad
networks were like not doing very well
and even though they were like well our
business is actually really good but
we're just going to keep getting
compared
to these low multiple other mobile ad
networks so they basically executed a
pivot mid-flight and we're like
well on our ad network the number one
advertisers are games that's who makes
the most money on our network that's who
pays the most money on our ad now or his
mobile games so they're like why don't
we just build mobile games and buy
mobile gaming studios and so they built
up this mobile gaming arm
that
i think does over a billion dollars a
year in revenue i think they do two
billion on just the like the amazon
basic of games
yeah exactly so they started buying up
these little partnering buying up
studios and building their own studio
in-house and then they would just use
their existing reach and their ad
network to like grow their own games and
uh insane and then they got valued much
higher because they had like a different
story than just we're a mobile ad
network and that's it so anyways
furcon's been doing crazy [__] but he's
been going all in since he was very very
young so when he was 15 he worked at
a.com uh during the uh like dot-com boom
like his dad was like hey um
i met this guy they raised like on
beverage.com is like this guy raised 50
million dollars on a powerpoint he needs
somebody to build his website he doesn't
know how you know how to build websites
like why don't you go work over there so
at 15 he's working at a.com
then he starts his own ecom site that's
like
selling uh like cool like mods for your
computer you know people like trick out
their cars with like rims and stuff he
was doing that for like your gaming
computer or stuff like that you could
have like a see-through case with like
blue liquid going through it or stuff
like that
and
he goes to san jose state so not like a
fancy school
freshman year he's like is he an
immigrant isn't it is he from
well yeah his family's they're pakistani
but they
they've lived he grew up at the bay area
so he grew up
that's part of the magic it's like his
dad worked i think at ibm and like when
he was like five years old his dad would
bring home like the early computer or
the early printer and be like let's
assemble this together so that's how he
learned how to do [__]
so um
so anyways he he's freshman freshman
year at san jose state he's like dude i
just keep leaving the classroom to take
calls because like you know we're out of
inventory or whatever and so he just
quits san jose state he goes all in on
the ecom thing he figures out one hack
with the ecom thing which was like
back then i think on google or yahoo or
somewhere where people were searching
for stuff you could just sort by
cheapest so he just wrote a bot that
would always price
what like their their main like high
selling sku one cent lower than whatever
the cheapest price was and it was like
his lost leader and it would always
bring somebody to the to the site and
that's what he that's when he decided to
quit school was he was in a class and
they were describing what a loss leader
is he's like oh that's the [__] i'm
doing with my like
i'm like i'm like selling this stuff at
a loss to get traffic he's like i don't
need to be here i'm learning this [__]
like in the real world so he just left
and just like i dropped out
and then he's like whatever goes on he
spends a couple years playing poker as
well like you know a bunch of different
crazy stuff comes back starts doing
startups
and now and so after we sell and after
app 11 goes public the guy never needs
to work again he's got all the money in
the world
and
i'm like so what are you going to do and
he's like
he's like i want to
like i was like i'm going to buy a big
space hey basically it's like he's
creating his heaven on earth which did
he buy that space or did he rent it it
looks beautiful he's renting that one
but he was looking at buying before then
when covet started happening he's like
i'm just going to lease these they're
all like dirt cheap leases now and like
i don't know he got a sick place over on
the presidio
yeah so he's in fort mason he's got like
i don't know
maybe
ten thousand twenty thousand twenty five
thousand square feet or something like
that it's crazy and he basically created
his heaven on earth which i've come to
realize is like
i that's actually what i respect the
most it's like i don't respect because
people will be like oh on one hand you
guys go all in on elon or brett adcock
these guys who go all in is that what
you love but you also love this guy
who's got this amazing lifestyle and
works four hours a month that's the same
thing
it's the same thing they're creating
their heaven on earth and i think that
is that my best description of what i
admire and what i want to do is create
my own little heaven on earth which
takes two i don't even like that
description i say they're taking the
world and they're just bending it over
their leg to help the shape that they
want it to be
you know what i mean they're just
they're they're spanking they're
spanking the world yeah
they're a dominatrix and the
earth is their uh
the recipient no they're just like
making the world
because that's what it feels like it
feels like they're forcing things
they're forced to see an industry and
they say and they really go get my belt
and then they bend the industry over and
they spank it yeah exactly
so he's also an all-in kind of guy
because he he basically immediately
created like a lot of work for himself
he rented out the space he puts 40
there's i went there to visit there's 40
people working in there i'm like who are
all these this is like a bunch of young
brown dudes like who are all these
indian dudes everywhere what are they
doing i invested in one of them because
they're just part of his thing i was
like fur con are these guys legit and he
like told me this huge explanation i was
like all right so just say yes or no and
i and i
say less yeah
yeah i actually want to just invest in
the index because actually individually
all of the ideas are a little bit crazy
one of these is gonna work i just don't
trust myself to pick the right one so i
actually have talking to him about like
how do i just index into all of your
crazy like i would like a piece of every
brown dude in this in this uh
under this roof here like how do i do
that and
i think we're gonna work it out but i
wanna tell you about one of the things
that i saw there so dude the guy i
invested in was a white guy
[__] oh
yeah
you're the nba gm drafting kyle forber
you should take lebron i think
um
so so one of the guys that one of the
guys i met in there they were doing
something called orangewood robotics
have you ever heard of this company no
but obviously i'm in
[Laughter]
yeah so i go in and there's a reason
it's called order but i'll explain in a
second so they go in and i go i walk in
and there's a bunch of people at their
computers and then there's
the big thing he he wanted to do was he
was like you know a lot of engineers
they want to work in a space with other
smart engineers that's cool
but
one of the things that engineers
struggle with he's like the first thing
i bought when i got money is i bought
like a 3d printer and you know then like
this robotics thing and then i brought
about this drone thing he's like i just
want to have a whole bunch of hardware
available for free to engineers that are
building stuff that requires the stuff
that's very expensive so they can come
and hack on these these tools and they
don't need to like go buy this
you know
fifteen thousand dollar machine that
just does this thing and so that's what
he did and so when i walk in i'm like
what's going on in there there's
basically a room with a bunch of robotic
equipment in there i walk in and there's
this company called orangewood
and what these guys are doing is
they basically are like i was like
explain what this is they go oh we have
this robot that can paint stuff
and i was like okay
why and they're like well
you know like you know look around this
room like you see that you see this you
know there's this process called powder
coating you ever powder coated something
and i was like you obviously don't know
what you're talking to yeah so i was
like no um i was like is that for donuts
what is that and he's like no
basically it's this like process where
you need to paint you know i still can't
expect by the way that was a that was a
good one thank you um
you do that thing in text where you're
like six out of ten eight out of ten on
any on any joke
that was a good one i like that one the
powder coating for donuts so so
basically they're like you know it takes
you know a specialist you have to you
know you have to hire higher labor
labor's really hard nowadays and it's
also like a chemically intensive process
it's not really that bad basically
powder coating like i do it with
motorcycles so like your motorcycle
frame is just metal and then they powder
coat it which is it kind of looks like
paint i don't actually know exactly how
it works but you do it in like a room
that's sealed and you do it with gloves
on and it's like you're putting it looks
like a powder on it and it's like a
sealant slash protected thing slash
paint
right so they basically trained this
robot to do it and what they do the
trick is that the world has changed
where there's now this like robotic arm
that's a general purpose robotic arm so
think of it like an iphone right it's a
piece of hardware that you could buy
that you could program to do anything
right so when steve jobs came out with
the iphone they were like this is iphone
it can access the internet it has a gps
inside and it can make phone calls like
that's what it could do
and from there you guys figure out the
rest right like initially they didn't
have the app store but then when they
did have the app store now all of a
sudden you get the flashlight app and
then the app that turns you know it's
like a ruler uses the camera to like
measure something then you get like
strava it's like we'll use the gps to do
this thing so it's basically like a
programmable general purpose tool so
that's what's happening with these
robotic arms
these guys wrote software to teach that
robotic arm they bought how to powder
coat things and then they taught it how
to paint floors and then they taught it
how to weld things so this thing could
literally just weld [__] together uh
they taught it how to um you know pick
and pack things so it could take it
could take things out of one place and
put it into another place based on what
it looks like
and
and the way you do it is like
you just write a program that that does
each of these functions and you need to
specialize it and then there's there's
more sophisticated ways they'll put a
camera on top and they'll teach it to
like recognize stuff so like my cousin
was doing this where he was teaching
this robotic arm
literally i went to his office and it
was straight up a robotic arm and a uh
like a hole and his whole thing was can
i get the arm to go in the hole and i
was like what's going on here guys like
this is a little like a sexual robot
someone is good and he's like no this is
where basically in the future electric
cars are going to need to get charged
but when they're self-driving there's no
driver to get out of the car and plug it
in
he's like so you need the charging
station to be able to automatically
attach to the car
otherwise we're never going to have
self-driving cars that work that are
electric because
who will fill them up you'll need a
person there always to be able to go do
this and they'll need basic gas
attendants at every gas station to do
this which in my mind i was like that
doesn't sound so bad but like you know
there's a reason he pivoted but the
point is they were training this arm to
be able to use the camera to find the
hole and exactly get in without
scratching the car and so there's like
this whole industry of people that are
doing this they're just figuring out how
to program these general purpose robotic
arms and they're making very interesting
businesses off them so these guys are
doing it with painting i thought that
was pretty cool because it's like a high
value thing like you rent it for 500
bucks for the day and it'll paint all
your [__] and it's like that's cheaper
than hiring a person to do it and more
reliable maybe because they'll do it
it'll do it like perfectly even every
single time you don't have like human
error
and so
the other one that that's interesting
like this is cafe x which you've
probably seen yeah yeah yeah in the
malls which is basically
starbucks yeah and like you see it
you're like oh what was stupid and then
you start thinking about it you're like
oh my god the implications here are
quite big
yeah no i saw that i was immediately
like this is this one of the smartest
ideas i've ever seen so if you haven't
seen cafe x because you're not like in
san francisco
imagine starbucks
but now shrink starbucks down to the
size of like a a jumbo vending machine
and it's see-through and inside is just
a robotic arm and you go you place your
order you're like i need my you know
cappuccino i want it you know whatever
double shot and i don't drink coffee so
i'll make it up but like you know oat
milk and two sugars and basically the
arm then starts to like move around
inside and it makes your coffee that it
hands it to you and then it waves and it
doesn't dance and it and you get to walk
away and basically you pay you know two
dollars fifty cents and you're getting a
robotic coffee so the why this is dope
is
it takes up like one tenth of the real
estate of starbucks
it has no like labor costs or very very
low labor costs it's just the person who
comes and cleans the robot at the end of
the day and refills the ingredients so
there's like you know very low labor
cost and the robot like never gets tired
never calls in sick it just like runs
all day and just makes the per the exact
same coffee all the time and it could do
that with like you know 100 drinks or
something like that and so
cafe x hasn't quite taken off i think
there's they did some stupid things and
i remember hearing that like at one
point like in the seed round the founder
only owned four percent of the company
or something they like effed up their
cap table or something like that yeah i
heard that too um
and so you know that that particular
startup i don't think it's going to work
but i'll be damned if this is not going
to be a thing like this is going to be a
thing it just makes too much it has such
an economic advantage and it only has
technology risks and i think people
really underestimate that because
most businesses have extreme market risk
we don't even know if the customers want
it and we don't know if they're going to
adopt it then it has but this has like
well if the customer wants it it's not
really a question the customer wants a
fast delicious coffee yes that's not
like that's not that hard to do
and instead of making starbucks as a
place where you go sit it's optimizing
for people who want to get in and get
out like subway stations and stuff like
that like people who are quickly on the
go
and has such a big financial advantage
if they can do it because the real
estate and the labor costs now the only
question is can you make the robot arm
work well enough and actually that's a
problem that engineers are good at
solving over like a 10-year period so
i'm trying to just do this math to make
sure i'm right um wow okay so check this
out so i i know a few a few of these
guys doing these startups that involve
so a lot of them use the word humanoid
have you heard that word
yeah don't like it yeah i don't like
humanoid but basically it's robots that
do jobs of humans like gas station
attendant so i was just curious and this
cafe x is interesting there's another
one that's doing it for pizza i think
it's called zoom is it called zoom
that was one of the popular ones
softbank put like i don't know 500
million dollars into it or something
ridiculous which sounds silly but i and
this is i only did this research while
we were talking it could be way off but
i'm looking at a government website it
seems legit
do you know what percentage of working
americans work in fast food
oh man it's gotta be high uh but i'm
gonna give you the homie move and i'll
say seven percent
no that was way too much i asked that
poorly so about
about three and a half million americans
work
uh in fast food jobs which is like a
point
that's that's significant dude that's
significant uh 10 of those work at
mcdonald's so mcdonald's employs like
250 300 000 people
um
it's kind of astonishing i'm i'm a
fairly libertarian person but when i
think of these things i'm like
what are these people going to do for
work i mean there's just that's only
we're only talking about fast
fast food you talk about all these other
things i mean potentially five or ten
percent of americans of workers it's
like you know they maybe don't have a
lot of that many skills like when these
things happen i'm like i don't know
what's gonna happen with these people
it's not a good situation it almost is
more scary than it is
interesting you know what i'm saying
yeah people always say that um
i don't know i just feel like
it's there's really two questions which
is like
a is this new no for forever technology
has been like making things easier and
getting rid of jobs like okay you know
maybe we were you know doing stuff by
hand on the fields and then we got the
tractor and that like maybe reduce the
number of people you needed by
10x in order to run a farm
and you know with all the automation by
the way the farming industry has massive
stuff subsidies i mean they like there's
some farmers that are so efficient and
so good and there's more nuance to this
so someone's going to correct me but
basically some farms my parents work in
the agriculture industry it's kind of
how i know this some farms are so big
and so good the government will pay you
money not to grow a crop because they
say you're going to screw up the whole
market if you overflow us with corn
yes it's called the farm act i believe
uh or is that the farm act there's a
there's a couple acts a couple bills uh
in in america where they will pay you
money not to do anything because they
say you're gonna disrupt you're gonna
you're gonna make too much
we don't want you screwing
yeah and so the farming thing is a good
example and what has happened is the
government is heavily involved
that sounds this sounds so stupid i i i
really oversimplified that but it is
basically the case where you get paid
not to do something
because you will disrupt the market too
much
that's insane to me i mean aren't there
people that need food and aren't there
are prices high higher than ever like
that's crazy to me that we're not for
like corn i mean corn i mean like
america does like two a few things
really well one we produce really good
entertainment so like our biggest export
you could say is like uh
culture you know movies and music and
fashion and the second best thing is
corn like our ability to create corn is
like phenomenal we create corn
so well uh i mean corn syrup is in
everything ethanol fuel is made out of
corn everything's made of corn we are
really good at making corn so i don't
know i think with corn i think we're
kind of we kind of nailed that one we
kind of that's a home run
yeah okay i don't know enough about this
to really speak on it but i guess what
my point is over time technology has
just gotten more and more
pervasive and it's like what's what
happened to all the horse carriage
drivers what happened to all the people
that worked in factories what happened
to all the people that did this and that
and the reality is like they shift they
shift around so you know some people
will become
robot attendants and they'll become good
at like managing and cleaning the robots
and
fixing them when they when they bug out
some people will shift into a new type
of labor and like whether that's they
become entertainers on social media they
become you know there's new jobs that
will get created from every single thing
that gets done and like you know what's
the other question is like what's the
alternative
do you pump the brakes on making things
better faster cheaper like that doesn't
seem like you it's possible or real or
like yeah like i'm not gonna let i'm not
gonna let like my feelings get away of
like progress and technology i'm just
saying like
it that doesn't mean that it's not
frightening
yeah i i just think you know there's a
little bit of carnage whenever any
change happens whether it's you know
change for the good or it's changed for
the bad right like i think in any
there's there's a little bit of
collateral damage along the way and the
question is like you know that also
creates opportunities because
if you created a business that re-skills
people not only are there going to be a
lot of people that need reskilling but
maybe the government will pay you to
help reskill workers in the economy so
the free market can come up with a
solution
to how to
absorb this labor how to reskill this
labor and do things like that so i don't
really worry about stuff like that but i
do think
that it's very interesting to me that
these robotic like these general purpose
robot robot like pieces can now be
programmed to do just a variety of
things that are otherwise you know today
human labor
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
have you seen this tv show called the
bear
i've seen a few episodes i haven't
finished it all right so
the background and the show isn't
necessarily the important topic here but
it's a topic i want to ask you about but
the background is basically a
restaurant in chicago the owner kills
himself
and the br the brother inherits this
restaurant and it's a mess and the
brother is a trained chef from french
laundry which is like the best
restaurant in the world and he comes to
this kind of like [__] restaurant
and he's got to turn it around so that's
the whole premise
and i'm watching this show and i used to
work at a restaurant like most kids if
you know 15 16 17 18 i worked at a
restaurant
and this show reminded this show
reminded me how miserable they are and
like this goes on the list like right
below like music festivals of things and
businesses that you should never start
and run from no matter almost no matter
how good they are and
are like this wait why music festivals
what's wrong with music festivals dude
any business that you could that you
spend 18 months working on and
[Music]
if it rains that day you're completely
screwed like that that's a one out of
you know 365 chance i mean more than
that it's more than one time a year but
like the odds that like rain come
and ruin your whole years of work that's
the worst that's like i don't want to
join that business
i mean like music festivals they're just
horrible and they're horrible because
the bigger and more people who that go
and the more money that you make the
worse the experience gets that's why i
always disliked conferences i was like
damn the better i make this for me the
worse it is for the attendee and thus
harder for the get them to come back
over and over again and with a
restaurant you see inside this kitchen
at the bear at the it's called like
chicago
beef i think uh you see behind the
scenes of the restaurant it is
impossible this is playing business on
the hardest mode possible people are
angry people are vulgar all the time i
remember when i used to work at a
restaurant like there was a huge uh
contingency of drug addicts you know you
get off work at 2 am what are you gonna
do you're gonna go immediately go to the
bar and get screwed up and then come
back to work next day at 11. lots of
drug addicts lots of people calling in
sick for work lots of people angry about
a vulgar hostility this looks like a
horrible business to be in
your sushi restaurant was probably a
little bit different than this but was
it at all similar to what i'm seeing the
bear
well ours wasn't just because a we only
ran it for three months and you know we
were only open and live for three months
and b we were the we were the labor for
most of that we only had a couple other
people
the but what the way i experienced this
was we went and worked in other
restaurants to shadow to learn how do
you actually run a restaurant right so
like we worked in other sushi
restaurants my buddy dan worked inside
of a noodles company to see like how
does a fast casual like process thing
work or whatever and how does that work
with a lot of salt
he was just like dude like because we
used to eat at these places he's like
don't order the tomato bisque i was like
the bisque it's a soup the soup is the
good thing he's like don't order the
tomato bisque
i was like what's wrong he's just like
bro you've never seen salt like you see
in the biscuit i was like
it's like somebody who is just like
traumatized by what they saw and it's
just like
dude those people in the back don't give
a [__] they're gonna put whatever they
want in this it does and the things that
they're supposed to put are so bad for
you
and uh this stuff just sits around and
like he's like don't don't eat this
stuff
i was like okay yeah sometimes the less
you know
like i remember when we were working in
the kitchen and we worked out of a
commissary kitchen so there's other
people there the food truck people would
come prep there the caterers and the
worst was the guy who would sell hot
dogs he had like a hot dog stand
not no offense but like he would just
come in with
350 hot dogs
he would pour them all into the sink
and we're like that's the sink where we
do everybody does their dishes in there
it's like pouring your hot dogs in a hot
tub and then he was like just started
turned up the water was just washing
them and then he was just like chucking
them to the side after they've been like
rinsed for a second
i was like first of all why are you
washing the hot dog why did this need
washing it was like if it came out of a
package you washed it you washed it in
the grossest sink possible and you just
threw it on the side like somebody's
gonna eat that like six hours i was like
i will never eat a hot dog okay
forget about what even went into the hot
dog which i think in itself is gross
like when you watch these documentaries
about like you know farming and stuff
like that and i was like just watching
this dude watch the hot dogs before
taking them to the ball game
by the way
you saying no offense is now going to be
my new neg so i'm going to be like i'm
just going to be talking about anything
like yeah dude i was running this guy
and he smelled so bad no offense and
i'm just going to start saying no
offense like all the time
and like i was out walking around the
streets and they were disgusting no
offense and
this person was so annoying no offense i
mean nothing wrong with annoying people
so no fans but
i'm gonna start saying no fuss i'm gonna
throw no offense there in there all the
time
that's amazing uh that's disgusting but
anyway this show what's interesting
about it though and this is a lot of
similarities i see in what you and i do
and what a lot of our friends do and a
lot of listeners do is
they are so passionate about this thing
and at first i was like why are they so
passionate about this and i started i
was like oh wait no this is just their
this is the just their shtick you know
my outlet's a little bit different but
it's like the same type of obsessed
um
they love it they love it so anyway cool
show and and i wanted to bring it up
because i i wasn't sure if it was
similar to your restaurant experience
i think it was like we used to do the
thing you'd get off at one am and then
you you know you the thing closed at
midnight you got to clean up prep for
the next day it's one before you get out
of there
and now you're hungry and tired you
didn't want to eat your own food so you
go to another restaurant they're getting
off they'll just cook for you for free
but then like you know two people are
doing cocaine in the bathroom and you're
like this isn't like you know the most
productive lifestyle the restaurant
industry i would say the bonding is very
like the camaraderie was amazing
and i would say there's something very
soulful about like feeding people uh
that's like really great but then the
hours are brutal it is business on hard
mode and there's a lot of like
degeneracy same thing with like poker i
used to play poker i loved the game of
poker i hated sitting in a casino
playing poker because i just felt like i
was surrounded by
so many degenerates and i was like this
is not a high quality of living like
just sitting here in this kind of
artificial air with this guy who's like
fell asleep next to me because he's been
here for 42 hours straight like this is
not who i want to surround myself with i
need to get out of this situation um let
me tell you about something that is the
opposite of that kind of a an inspiring
work environment
so i saw this tick tock and it just i
saw two tic tacs i don't remember i want
to tell you about i'm not going to play
them here because it'll take a little
too long maybe in the youtube video we
can we could play them but i want to
know if you've seen these one went viral
so it was did you see this viral clip of
the
picture on the mets
coming out to the uh coming out to pitch
he's like the closer so he was coming
out to do his thing and it's normally
on tv they just cut to commercial um in
between like the chain like the the
lineup change because it's like whatever
it's gonna be two minutes the guy's
gotta warm up he's gonna run out from
the bullpen that takes a little while
baseball's slow already he's got a warm
up then whatever they usually come back
but this time they stuck with it so they
showed did you see this clip or am i
just should i describe it keep going
keep going the show from behind the guy
like walking out from the thing emerging
basically into the stadium so they have
a dope camera shot oh and they're using
that ufc lens have you noticed all these
guys are using this yeah the ufc has got
this beautiful lens where it like blurs
out the background special yeah
and then they and the guy normally comes
out to this um
song i don't know what it's called it's
like whatever i don't know the guy timmy
timmy trumpets is like the singer you
know
he's featured on it this guy with his
trumpet but the mets had brought the guy
there live and so he was kind of hiding
and he comes out he's got his little
trumpet he's got a microphone on the end
of the trumpet and he starts playing the
song and he's playing the song live the
guy's running out into like the roaring
crowd and it's just so dope
and now timmy trumpet takes center stage
as edwin diaz gets ready
to come in
[Music]
[Applause]
he's myself
[Music]
all right business is cool but like
god sports and music just have this
special thing this special moment these
special feelings that you you can't
there's nobody is that passionate about
our podcast nobody is that passionate
about this piece of software but when
this moment hits the guy runs out he's
the hero the trumpet guy's there he's
playing the crowd's going nuts and it
was just like this special
moment and it was a lot of showmanship
and so i i watched that and i get this
feeling i'm like that was dope
i'm glad that they went that extra mile
for that showmanship does that create i
will never watch baseball but like i'm a
fan of like this guy that song you don't
watch baseball at all right now way too
slow for you right two slow too boring
uh used to love it but you know when i
was a kid so now
i swipe up on tick tock the next video
is this teacher
and it says uh
revealing the music the year musical
part one and i'm like i don't know i
just hung around for an extra second to
watch he goes he goes all right
and this year the musical is gonna be
and he like reveals the whiteboard and
there's nothing there and then there's
like a small envelope and everyone's
like
wait what and then he's like he opens up
the envelope there and he's like it's
gonna be hold up this just says
turn on the computer
and then the students are like what's
going on here and clearly the teacher
had kind of set up a bit to like just
make it more fun and like you know
everybody loves this because it's like
here's this teacher of like a middle
school or high school or something like
that they didn't have to do this like
you know most teachers are just sort of
like they want to just roll out the tv
on the black you know like trolley and
just be like all right guys just watch
this [__] movie for an hour and like
just leave right like
being a teacher is exhausting and like
it's easy it would be it would be very
easy to phone it in most don't and some
like this guy go the extra mile so now
he clicks his computer
and it's a video and it's him
and he's like hey it's me from the
future and he's just like it's a silly
bit but he's talking back to it he's
like what are you doing here he's like i
don't know i read the envelope it said
turn the computer he's like you just
gotta do whatever the envelope says and
it's like it goes back and forth so he's
like doing this skit with himself
and he's like he's like uh and it
freezes and then it freezes and it says
wait everybody look under your desk and
like one kid has this special thing and
it was like this elaborate almost like
an escape room leading up to this reveal
and i saw that and so what was the plan
video was viral the play was like i
don't even remember it was like
it was like not something like that cool
it was like you know
les miserables whatever it was like
who cares
but like by the end the students are
going nuts because they're so invested
at this point they sort of midway
through they realized
okay
this is cheesy but i'm into it he's
doing this for us and like all right i
want to know he built up tension
and the reason i bring up these examples
is because there is a word that my
trainer uses all the time and nobody
else in my life i know talks about this
my trainer all the time goes yeah you
gotta have a little showmanship
and showmanship is a word
that i think like for most of us doesn't
even enter our brain on a day-to-day
basis
and my trainer will always tell me he's
like you know
he'll be at starbucks before you know
he'll go get a coffee before our session
and he'll always tell me these stories
he's like you know i decided to add a
little showmanship so i told him my name
was blah blah and they wrote it on the
cup and then by the time the person was
done you know i told them like you know
whatever uh you know he'll you know
he'll say you know bond james bond and
then they'll just laugh they'll have a
little chuckle and then they'll write
bond
he's like add the comma james bond and
then they'll do it they'll laugh a
little more and now he just like made
their day a little more entertaining
than it was than it had to be if he just
said my name is john and okay cool
you're just another john and so he
always talks about adding showmanship
and it's just like walking through life
and just identify little moments
where you could do something slightly
different than like than the norm and i
have a like i have kids now so i do this
with my daughter all the time
like we used to have such a hard time
getting her to eat and my mother-in-law
came over and like you know as a classic
sort of like mother-in-law thing she's
like always being like do this do that
you guys are doing this wrong like you
know
it's true she's got like i don't know 30
years of parenting experience we got two
but like it's also really annoying to be
told what to do and how to parent better
and how to like do this do that so we're
normally my default was kind of annoyed
but one day she was like
uh she was like um like the milk bottle
was like way less i said how did you get
her to drink the milk
and she's like oh she loves to drink out
of this like little measuring cup
instead of like the normal cup
and she goes change of presentation
and i go and i was like and so now me
and my wife will always joke is where i
was like oh god so annoying she was
telling us what to do but then like like
sometimes she does pull this like rabbit
out of her hat and like you know we'll
do something my dad doesn't want to do
it and then we just change the like
change the presentation of how we're
getting her to do it and all of a sudden
she's super locked in like i do this now
when i feed her i couldn't get her to
eat vegetables so i decided to create
like my own version of the show uh
chopped so i'm like okay close your eyes
i'm gonna put one thing in front of you
and in front of your brother and like
take the bite and then you need to tell
me is it one thumbs up two thumbs up or
thumbs down and then i do a huge
reaction based on the score they give me
and she's like i want to play the close
eyes game i want to play the clothes
eyes game because she and i can get her
to eat a whole meal if i'm willing to
basically create a television show out
of it it's really like exhausting for me
but honestly it's like also kind of fun
and it gets her to eat anything whereas
otherwise that's actually even more
exhausting to try to feed her something
she doesn't want and so this idea of
showmanship keeps weaving its way into
my life
and i wanted to bring this up because
for somebody out there
they're going to basically use this as
like your word of the day find a way to
like weave in a little more showmanship
into what you're doing a little change
of presentation as we say
have you do you think about this at all
i do and so i was i wanted i had to go
find it but have you heard of this guy
named tren griffin he's like this like
60s maybe
he's 60 something years old white dude
and his twitter bio just says like i
used to work with bill gates at
microsoft so you're like oh you're
automatically like wise and interesting
so
he has a blog called 25 iq
and i was reading it the other day and
he had this article called a dozen
beliefs about business money and life
that kanye west shares with other great
entrepreneurs and investors i was like
oh that's an interesting title and the
very first line has always stuck with me
and it's about con it's from kanye and
it says for me first of all dopeness is
what i like the most
dopeness people who want to make things
as dope as possible and and by default
make money from it
and i always think about that quote
because i also get caught up in like
well this does this and this does this
and this does this and so it makes money
and i'm like
oh yeah but this is super lame and not
that cool and like this sucks my soul
what am i doing like this isn't awesome
you know and it's like well what is
awesome i don't know exactly how to
explain it but i do think about that all
the time where i'll try to like nickel
and dime things about what i'm gonna buy
or like the other day i bought some uh
uh like air force ones and i was like
trying to like get like this cheap ones
and i'm like bruh
i can get the 250 air force once and i
don't have to justify it like if they're
cool they're cool they're dope i'm doing
it no matter what and i always have to
justify like certain decisions to myself
was like
this is just cool do it because it's
cool i only have one life so yeah i
think about this all the time
yeah do it because it's cool i think
it's a great like you know uh
for most people who listen to this
podcast they're probably like
high achiever types and they're probably
rational and like analytical about a lot
of decisions
and so i think for that audience
actually you need to add more of this
other ingredient which is the yeah for
sure do it because it's cool eff it
don't measure it and also
honestly the same thing can either be
done boring or dope
it's like it's not the thing that's dope
yeah it's how you do the thing that's
dope or not dope and so you know the
broccoli itself wasn't dope when i
turned it into this game i made it more
dope for her and therefore she has a
different experience and i have a
different experience in doing it and if
i consistently do that well there's just
more experiences throughout my day that
are dope and what's a dope life it's a
bunch of dope days it's a bunch of dope
days it's a bunch of dope experiences
throughout the day right you just break
it down into moment like you can break
it down into its atomic unit and realize
that like
the boringness or like routine of your
life is uh like you know in your own
hands and if you just add a little
showmanship to yourself and to the
people around you you can kind of change
how the experience feels
in many ways but like you know i'm
seeing how this helps me and i wanted to
share this little framework do you
remember boosted skateboards
yeah these are all over the place in san
francisco people would like
skateboarding up the hill because it was
like you know san francisco is so hilly
and it's like look like magic how are
they going up this and now like electric
scooters are the norms like the bird
scooters and all those so that's like
considered normal now but about eight
years ago boosted skateboards came out
with this longboard skateboard that
would go 25 miles an hour i remember i
bought one and it was crazy it was so
cool and i met the founder and i was
like tell me about your background he's
like oh i worked at nasa and i was doing
this other thing then i thought about
like working in the government and like
sending people to mars i thought that
had been like interesting but i decided
to launch this this skateboard company i
was like well
you know are you interested in
skateboards he's like no
i was like were you interested in this
other thing he's like no not really i
was like well you know why'd you go to
skateboards he goes because it's [__]
awesome and i remember i remember him
saying that and i was like
well yeah you got a point yeah yeah it
is it is awesome and i when he told me
that i just i remember a shift happened
in my life it's like oh yeah yeah
that's a that's a good addition i gotta
add that to my like box of checks check
box you know of things to do like you
know it makes money it makes my mom
proud uh it's effing awesome uh i
remember him saying that and i was like
oh yeah you're right
right yeah tony robbins has a thing he
says which is like you will uh you will
only meet the you'll meet your standards
not your not your desires
and basically like a standard is like
more of a must a standard is like you
know i'm not gonna eat at a restaurant
if i saw flies flying around everywhere
that's below my standard and so an
important thing to figure out is like
what are my standards for the things
that i do in my life
it sounds like for this guy one of his
standards for like what do i work on is
is this awesome or not whereas for a lot
of people that [__] is completely
optional nice to have for sure
it's not part of the standard and then
you meet certain people and this is the
best thing you could do like why do
people have that phrase of like
you are the average of the five people
you spend your most the most time with
is because it's because fundamentally
you will adopt the standards of the
people you're around
it's not because they'll teach you
things it's not because they'll give you
good advice
it's because fundamentally you will
adopt the sanders like i remember we
have a couple friends who are like you
like you're one of my friends who's very
fit i have other friends that are that
are very fat or they care about being
very fit
and whenever there's a question of like
all right yeah let's go grab some food
what do you guys want to eat
it's like i know that i can't suggest
you know
i can't cheesecake factory's not on the
list you know like i can't i can't take
these guys there that's not their their
standard is that that's not what they
eat and so like you know i automatically
i will start to only suggest and
therefore only go to places that i know
meets their standard of what they they
consider for the record i [__] with
cheesecake factory hardcore
chicken piccata all day
yeah i'm not above it
yeah we have a couple friends that like
it's like oh cool like what
uh you ordered the gordita what's good
here i've never been to this place
dude can i talk about something that
that i can't decide if actually and we
could wrap up with it i can't decide if
it's awesome and dope or not so
basically i want to give like people
perspective on you and i's like behind
the scene so you and i shawn and i get
dm'd or cold email all the time and a
very common thing is hey can i like give
you content to share and i'll do it for
free or something like that and the bad
thing about freeze you kind of get what
you pay for so when it's free [__]
you're like oh there's too much work i
don't want to share your stuff on
twitter i don't want to share your stuff
on whatever it's just it's not good i
don't want to work on it
for some reason i gave one of these kids
a chance and i i say no to everyone i
gave this kid a chance he dm to me and i
was like you know i'll give you i'm
going to give you my password to my tic
toc and i want you to impress me i go
send me a picture of your social
security number card send me a picture
of your boss and send me a picture of
your driver's license and he did and i
go all right if you [__] i was like
because i was like if you screw me over
here i'm gonna get you back so like i
have your information um
here's my password to my tick tock i
gave him the password
by the way yeah that's great
like if you do something bad to me i'm
gonna get you and so i um
i gave him my password to my ticket give
me your mother's address because i will
be mailing her your index finger in an
envelope if you [__] yourself because
there's like no information that i could
get to like get back at this person you
know what i mean like i'm like i need
you to have something yeah we're
imbalanced you can really screw me by
posting on my account what am i going to
i need to equally be able to screw you
okay
continue yeah and i gave him the
password to my tick tock it's been one
week so in one week this kid has taken
you and i's videos and posted him two a
day on tick tock and in six days maybe i
think one week's tomorrow he's gotten
1.5 million views and i went from
basically zero to like not have an
account to like eight or nine thousand
followers as of now a handful of videos
have gotten one got five hundred
thousand one got seven hundred thousand
a bunch got fifty thousand plus
uh 150 or 200 000 likes tens of
thousands of comments and
i'm like that's kind of interesting but
i don't exactly believe that this is
true like i don't know if this is true
and so i was like post a video where
there's a call to action and so we did a
video about my favorite book and it shot
up the charts and i'm like all right
people are actually like these people
are somewhat engaged they're like buying
a business
like on amazon you mean yeah so uh and
this is the second this is the second
time that i did this so one time i
recommended a book and before i
recommended it i took a picture of its
rating on amazon and then i recommended
it and the next day it was number one in
the entrepreneurship category and number
one in the business category uh and i
took screenshots of it to like prove it
and uh it was it was the book called how
to get rich that that tweet reached two
million people this other video that i
did i talked about the same book and it
shot up i think now it's number one in
entrepreneurship again
and it's uh that video has been viewed
500 000 bro let's write our own book if
you've got this kind of oprah influence
i mean
why you referencing this guy's dead he
doesn't need your help come on let's
write our own book let's see okay yeah
look uh how to get rich is now number 30
in all of audible and originals it's
number one in the small business
category
yeah look up how to get rich go look at
right now look at the categories like it
like skyrocketed after this video
and i can't decide if this whole tick
tock game is that i should just do it
where it's like it's just simpler which
is just like if you're a real person i i
don't know if these tick tock views are
real or not if you're real
just put like a one in the car just type
the number one i am going to see who's
gonna do that you know because because i
feel the same way about these tick tock
views it's like
our favorite words little little fugazi
little fugazi there's a fugazi for your
aussie element to these tick tock views
it's like how
you know is this really 1.5 million
people what does this mean did they
actually watch it what's going on here
if so that's amazing but i'm you know
some things can be too good to be true
uh but that's cool yeah you've been
showing up on my feed for what it's
worth but i think it's because we're i
have like two tick tock friends you're
one of them
this one this book video got
fourteen thousand views a couple of them
got seventy thousand fifty thousand one
got seven hundred thousand lots of
twenty thousands i can't decide if this
is real and if it is real
i don't wanna sound like gary vee but
i'm like oh everyone should do this like
this is easy this is this kid in miami
he's just doing this and he just spun
this up and it's working wonderfully and
like you i don't i mean i think you're
actually better than me but i'm not like
that charismatic i'm not that good why
is this game so easy and is this game is
it real and also honestly is it worth it
i'm not convinced that it's worth it
well if you can spike a book to number
one in the charts that shows that
there's some value there there's some
influence there like that's not just a
number but yeah it's kind of lame like
the most
most there's a lot of amazing stuff on
tick tock basically these 18 year old
kids are like the most creative people
i've ever seen but then there's guys
like you and me these like money people
and influencers and
everyone's doing the same [__] circle
jerk alex or mosey stuff and it's really
lame and so i don't know how to make it
interesting and right now what i'm doing
i think it's not interesting but the
results are incredible
yeah
but is it effing awesome to go back to
your standard tbd tbd you know what's
happening awesome is when you create
content and then like someone like
legitimately famous and cool like hassan
like hollers at you and then you're like
yeah this is the awesome part about it
so like
like that you know what i mean like
that's worth all the lame tweets that
you and i have done is getting to hang
out with like a couple of really cool
people
you know what's cool about selling your
soul
sometimes someone pays that price for it
you know what's cool about being a [__]
is the money
we're out
[Music]
you